this
is the virus a tiny organism less than
one millionth of an inch in diameter
magnified here thousands of times by the
electron microscope
this the disease caused by the virus
one which has plagued man since recorded
history
this the scientist dr john enders of
harvard
whose work made possible an effective
vaccine which can prevent the disease
this the place where the vaccine is
tested and produced for use throughout
the world west point
pennsylvania and this
the vaccine itself the end product of
medicine's long match
with measles
many parents think of measles as just a
common nuisance which makes their
children feel miserable and keeps them
out of school for a while but physicians
today
know that measles is more than a
nuisance it can bring on bacterial
infections
can cause fatal pneumonia and in some
cases encephalitis
inflammation of the brain each case
needs good
medical care it is not so much because
of the usual rash and fever symptoms of
measles that the doctor says he'll check
back in a day or so
but rather to be sure the young patient
is not developing serious complications
electroencephalograms indicate that half
the patients with natural measles
show some brain involvement during the
disease
after the disease has passed most
patients such as this boy being tested
in philadelphia's children's hospital
show a return to a normal brain wave
pattern
a distinct contrast to the abnormal
pattern recorded during the disease
still in those patients who showed the
abnormal encephalogram during their
illness
the possibility of future emotional
instability
or mental deficiency or even mental
retardation cannot be ruled out
fortunately only about one measles
patient in a thousand develops
encephalitis
as of this time measles is by far our
most serious epidemic childhood disease
although nearly half a million cases are
reported each year
the actual number is probably closer to
four million
in 1961 after the polio vaccines had
reduced the deaths from that disease to
90
that same year 434
measles deaths were reported
in the less developed countries of the
world the toll taken by measles is much
greater
in nigeria it is estimated that one out
of four babies contracting measles
dies from it the tragic toll of measles
is also told in a neighboring republic
upper volta
where in one village an epidemic killed
113
out of 115 children who got the disease
across the ocean in chile measles
accounts for half
of all childhood deaths from acute
communicable diseases
each year
thus now as it has for centuries past
measles takes its toll of human life
it was a persian physician named razies
who gave the first classical description
of measles 10 centuries ago
he and other arabian physicians first
suggested that measles
is a distinct and separate disease it
had often been considered a form of the
pox
but these early doctors described and
treated the symptoms of the disease
not the cause there were many remedies
but no prevention
the cause remained a mystery
then in the 18th century the light began
to dawn on some of the causes of
infectious disease
jenner of england pasture of france coke
of germany
founded the science of bacteriology
with improved microscopes came the
microbe hunters they identified bacteria
grew them and experimented with them in
their laboratories
their search pointed the way to
discovery of another disease agent
a millimicrobe the virus and to the
development of a new medical research
specialty
pyrology
at hospitals and research centers today
virology is a major and growing
scientific discipline
and in a laboratory attached to
children's hospital in boston
is one of the nation's most respected
virologists
harvard scientist and nobel prize winner
dr
john enders in 1953
a few years after dr ender's work paved
the way for the polio vaccines
he and his team turned their attention
to measles
the first objective to find and to grow
the measles virus
blood samples taken by dr thomas peebles
from children with natural measles
were injected into cultures of human
kidney cells and incubated
with techniques like these being carried
out today by dr samuel katz
tissue cultures brought from the
incubator are checked for any changes in
the cells
obtaining even one successful growth of
pure virulent measles virus
is one of the most difficult laboratory
achievements
finally in 1954 one culture obtained
from an eleven-year-old measles patient
named david edmundson begins to show
remarkable changes in cell structure
these might be caused by the measles
virus
dr enders is called in to observe it
to prove that it is the measles virus
they decide to inject it
as dr katz demonstrates here into the
only animals that will contract the
disease
monkeys monkeys which have never been
exposed to measles
in a few days when the monkey develops
measles they
know they have isolated and grown the
edmondson strain of the measles virus
now they discuss the longest and in many
ways the most difficult task of all
how to attenuate or weaken the virus so
that it will produce antibodies and thus
provide immunity
without transmitting the disease itself
it's a little like walking on a
tightrope
the virus is grown first in one tissue
culture then in another
human kidney tissue human amnion
egg amnion chick embryo
it is transferred
it is incubated always carefully watched
and safeguarded against bacterial
infection at
every stage as the weeks pass
the virus makes 72 passages in all
before dr
enders decides it's ready for the next
tests with experimental animals
two groups of monkeys are used one group
is given the attenuated virus as a
vaccine
the other group is not vaccinated later
both groups are given the full strength
measles virus
in a few weeks the results are evident
the monkeys that were not vaccinated
develop measles the ones like this one
that were given the experimental vaccine
show no signs of measles but they have
developed protective antibodies
dr enders and dr katz now know that they
have developed for the first time
a vaccine which will provide safe
protection against measles
it only remains to test the attenuated
live virus vaccine with humans
starting first with children at a state
school dr katz then inoculates
volunteers who come to his lab at the
hospital
the results are most encouraging and
sparked interest throughout the world of
virology
one who saw the importance of moving
forward with this breakthrough
was dr morris hilleman director of virus
and cell biology
at the merck sharp and dome research
laboratories in west point pennsylvania
with cultures of attenuated virus from
dr ender's lab
dr hilleman dr eugene bynak and
colleagues
undertake development of larger
experimental quantities
at the same time dr hilleman draws up
the design of the next critical step
broad scale clinical testing
collaborating with dr hilleman is a
group at children's hospital
philadelphia
headed by dr joseph stokes nationally
known pediatrician and medical scientist
here with him
doctors robert e weibel j ronald helenda
and charles m riley map out a plan for
field trials in southeastern
pennsylvania
more than fifteen hundred children and
their parents cooperate
one group of children receives the live
vaccine by injection
the trial also studies how gamma
globulin given in the other arm
modifies reactions to the vaccine
another set of children for comparison
receives injections that do not contain
the live vaccine
a blood sample taken from each child
before vaccination
tells which children have not previously
had the disease
these samples are analyzed in the
research laboratory
another sample taken four weeks later
shows whether the child has developed
antibodies to the vaccine
then over the next year or so a close
check is kept to see if any of the
children contract the real disease
the results fulfill all expectations
the vaccinated children are protected
none of them get measles when exposed to
it
from new york university dr saul krugman
reports similar findings
as does dr fred mcrum at the university
of maryland
the trials spread across the country the
vaccine is tested in 18 states from the
eastern seaboard to california
as the data from all these field trials
accumulate
answers to earlier questions emerge the
live measles vaccine is producing a high
level of immunity
safely consistently and the immunity
appears to be long lasting
answers are also emerging on the
problems of large-scale production and
quality control
as manufacture gets underway in the
biological laboratories at west point
pennsylvania
the less developed countries in africa
watch this progress with great interest
helping them launch studies of the
vaccine are first the u s
armed forces epidemiological board and
later the world health organization and
u s public health service
it was to the national institutes of
health in 1962 that an urgent request
came from one of these african nations
upper volta satisfied with preliminary
testing
asks for a massive vaccination effort
help us
protect our children before measles
strikes again
begun in time it could save thousands of
lives
the response is immediate to help train
local teams and study the immunization
of this population
the public health service sends a
medical team from its division of
biologic standards
vehicles are supplied by the agency for
international development
the vaccine is contributed by merck
sharp and dome
the drum speaks to the people come to
the village
the doctors are here with the medicine
it can protect your children and the
people do come
bringing their children bringing their
hopes and fears
at each village the jet inoculator used
is carefully explained
then begins the long hard job of giving
the life-saving vaccine to the children
as soon as one village has been
protected the team must move on to the
next
everywhere they are greeted by huge
crowds
the vaccine must be kept refrigerated to
protect it from the intense african heat
at each new location the inoculator is
cleaned and checked
the lines seem endless
but all the children must get the
vaccine
village after village the people come by
the thousands
the team works around the clock
at last the work is done by march 1963
700 000 children in upper volta receive
live virus measles vaccine
many thousands of lives may have been
saved
that same month the department of health
education and welfare licenses the
vaccine for general use in the united
states
the surgeon general of the united states
public health service dr luther terry
has this to say
over the past several years measles
vaccines have been successfully tested
both in this country and abroad this
painstaking
evaluation was made possible by the
cooperative effort of scientists
both in and out of government by
physicians
by the drug industry and by thousands of
unselfish and courageous parents
who have committed their children to
participate in the field trials
the secretary of health education and
welfare has now licensed the vaccines
for general use
as increasing numbers of children are
vaccinated
we will be well on the way to
eradicating a disease that down through
the centuries
has killed millions of children and left
others impaired
mentally and physically all of those who
have contributed in any way
to this cause for better health can be
proud of a great achievement
within 48 hours of official government
licensing
supplies of the vaccine are ready for
shipment to doctors throughout the
country
today production of the vaccine is in
full swing
protected at each step by the elaborate
manufacturing controls established by
industry
together with the federal government
of the live virus vaccine begins with
fertile chicken eggs
to assure absolute purity the eggs are
taken from select
disease-free chickens kept in strict
sanitary isolation
the eggs are opened and the embryos are
carefully removed
they are minced and washed
then further broken down by a chemical
substance that reduces the tissue to
individual cells
it is only in living cells that the
virus can grow
to keep these cells alive and growing a
special nutrient is prepared
a precise number of cells is counted and
introduced into each bottle
then the measles virus is introduced 80
percent of the culture bottles are
infected
the other twenty percent are used as
controls they provide a way to check
against any possible impurities in the
cells
the cells attach themselves to the walls
and in the infected bottles the virus
grows in the cells
now begins a three-week period in which
the nutrient is periodically replaced
the cells are rinsed and the growth is
carefully watched
the fluid now taken from the culture
bottles contains a high concentration of
measles virus
the individual harvests are pooled
together also a stabilizer is added
and samples are removed for testing
finally the entire pool of vaccine is
filtered
this at last is the pure live virus
vaccine
it is frozen at minus 75 degrees to
await results of final testing
it takes 137 days to produce the vaccine
96 of these are devoted to meticulous
quality control testing
more than 35 separate tests are
performed to ensure potency
safety and other measures of quality
control
for each person involved in the actual
production of the vaccine
eight people devote their time to
testing and control
finally the vaccine which is passed all
of the tests is thawed and transferred
to individual bottles
these are then freeze dried capped and
sealed
the end result is a single dose bile of
the live attenuated virus measles
vaccine
but the real story of a vaccine is told
in the fears and smiles of a little girl
who today is given greater protection
than ever before against the infectious
diseases of childhood
there remain other viruses to be
isolated other vaccines to come
but they will and like this little girl
millions of children over the world will
have an even safer
and healthier life
so
you